It’s the year 1325 and the Bologneze and
Modenze armies are about to square off at
what has been called one of the “bloodiest
medieval battles” in Italy but also one
of the dumbest, because this was, the war
of the Bucket.
To understand why the war started we have
to look at the political climate it started
in.
And for that we’ll have to go back all the
way to 800 CE, with the crowning of the first
Holy Roman Emperor Charlemagne by the bishop
of Rome.
And even though Charlamagne didn’t realise
it back then, his crowning by the bishop of
Rome set in to motion the centuries long struggle
between the European kingdoms and the church.
Specially as it pertains to the Holy Roman
Empire.
How did this happen?
Well the first thing you have to understand
is that the bishop of Rome is the pope and
Charlemagne was the one who appointed the
bishop of Rome, who was then the one who crowned
Charlemagne as the Holy Roman Emperor.
Which created a weird circular division of
who actually had power over whom.
On top of that Charlemagne's appointment of
the pope, set the precedent of European kings
appointing their own bishops and other church
officials in their own lands, because if a
King can appoint the bishop of Rome why can’t
he then appoint any other bishop.
However Charlemagne also set the precedent
of the pope crowning the Holy Roman Emperor.
So if you were the ruler who controlled the
appointment of the Bishop of Rome, you were
also the one who controlled the crowning of
the Holy Roman Emperor, in theory anyways.
This resulted in the fact that after Charlemagne
the Germanic and northern italian lands that
became the continuation of the HRE turned
in to a political battleground over the control
of the Papal succession.
With often times the ones who controlled it
being unsurprisingly also the Kings of the
Germans and Holy Roman Emperors.
But all this, changed around 1050 when the
Papacy actively started to reform the appointment
of the bishop of Rome and diminish the nobilities
control over them.
And when Henry the 4th became the 6 year old
king of the Germans, he clearly didn’t have
enough experience at the time to handle the
delicate relationship between the king and
the pope.
So the church council in Rome seized on the
opportunity and restructured the rules of
the Papal succession creating the college
of cardinals as the sole body fit to appoint
a pope.
This meant that no longer could a ruler control
the appointment of the pope at least to such
an extend as they did up until now.
This created many problems within Europe although
I am going to be focusing on just the Holy
Roman Empire.
For one, Henry the 4th now no longer a kid,
denounced the current pope Gregory the 7th
as iligitement since he wasn’t appointed
by any king.
The Pope on the other hand denounced Henry
the 4th for being an illegitimate ruler of
the HRE since he wasn’t officially crowned
by the Pope.
On top of that even though the bishop of rome
wasn’t appointed by the nobility anymore,
all the other bishops and church officials
around Europe still where.
Which meant that they were more loyal to their
feudal lord then the church.
The Pope tried to remedy this through several
dubious power grabbing moves of using the
tradition of investitures to control the appointment
of church officials.
This resulted in a lot of political intrigue
and instability throughout europe and even
a 50 year old civil war in Germany, as the
factions loyal to the nobility and the pope
fought over who had the rights of appointing
church officials.
It ended in 1122 with an agreement called
the Concordat of Worms.
Where the Nobility could retain some of its
control over the appointment of church officials
but the Pope was finally recognized as having
some power in the actual appointment process.
And even though this treaty settled certain
problems, it resulted in the fact that now
you had two opposing factions roughly on equal
footing.
Meaning that throughout most of the middle
ages there was lots of continuous political
maneuvering, intrigue and battles, between
the supporters of the church and the state.
And as it pertains to the Italian part of
the HRE, these divisions played a vital part
in the political landscape of the various
Italian city states.
This is because the area was kind of a proxy
battle ground between the HRE and the Papacy.
It properly started off 45 years after the
concordat of worms in 1167 with the foundation
of the Lombard League.
This league was a coalition of various Italian
city states that didn’t like the fact that
the Holy Roman Emperor declared direct imperial
control over them.
And suprise suprise the league was supported
by the Papacy.
The Holy Roman Emperor Frederick 1st lead
an army to italy but was defeated by the lombard
league at the battle of Legnano, and had to
sue for peace several years later.
This peace treaty recognized the Holy Roman
Emperor as the ruler of northern Italian city
states, but it also gave the Italian cities
a lot of autonomy, which proved problematic.
This is because after gaining all this autonomy
many, in fact all the Italian city states
started to have a big rivalry amongst each
other.
And this political environment proved to be
perfect for the next stage of the church vs
the HRE power struggle.
With cities either starting to be loyal to
the “Church Party” called the Guelphs
(Guelfi) or the imperial party called the
Ghibellines (Ghibellini).
However these divisions developed their own
little weird dynamics outside of the overarching
church vs HRE plot.
Cities would sometimes not even care what
each party stood for and chose their allegiances
according to what was the most politically
and economically beneficial to them.
For example the church party tended to be
more prominent in large mercantile cities
as the Emperor was the main threat to their
wealth and trade networks.
On the other hand the imperial party tended
to be more prominent in smaller cities and
the countryside that often times felt threatened
by the bigger mercantile cities.
On top of that, even though some cities where
starch pro church party or pro imperial party,
other cities didn’t mined switching their
allegiances if it suited them.
Plus some cities had bickering imperial and
church factions that would often times fight
against each other over the control of the
city.
And even though it was the power struggle
between the Holy Roman Emperor and Pope that
started these parties, the northern italian
city states took it up a notch.
Your allegiance to one or the other party
started to affect many other things outside
of just your pro church or pro empire leanings.
Any big and small issues or disagreements
started to be split amongst party lines.
And not just that, depending on what party
you were associated with, it affected what
taverns and shops you where allowed in to,
what cities you could trade in, how you dressed
and what side you put the feather on your
hat on, and even the way you cut certain fruits.
The allegiances of some cities to its party
bacem so strong that you can tell what party
a city supported by just looking at its coat
of arms today.
If has a white cross on a red field it supported
the imperial party, if it had a red cross
on a white field it supported the church party.
These divisions came to a boiling point during
the 13th century interregnum of the Holy Roman
Empire.
This was a 67 years long succession crisis
within the HRE where the princes were unable
to agree on a new king.
This instability combined with the various
pretender kings and the continues power struggle
between the HRE and the papacy was the final
straw for northern italy.
And even though there were battles between
the imperial and church factions prior to
the interregnum, the interregnum period took
it in to an overdrive.
The imperial vs church faction struggle took
a bit of a respite after the 1289 church party
win at the Battle of Campaldino.
This battle drastically diminished the power
and consequently the threat of the imperial
party in Italy, and because Florence was the
one leading the church faction in this battle,
they became a prominent if not the main power
within the party.
But now since the church party seemingly won,
with the imperial party being on its back
foot.
The Florentine church faction ironically started
to be concerned with the increasing Papal
influence within the city.
So a split within the church faction happened.
With the supporters for more papal control
being called black guelphs (black church party)
and the supporters for less papal control
being called white guelphs (white church party).
The black church party with the support of
the pope eventually won and most of the white
church party members were exiled from the
city.
Which included the famous Dante who after
his exile went on to write the Dante’s inferno.
But I digress.
Even though this church party division was
most prominent in Florence it showed the underlying
problems and disunity within the faction.
And the imperial party wasn’t any better
with Emperor Henry 7th stating that he was
disgusted by both sides actions, pointing
out how some members strayed vary far from
the initial party goals.
This was because at this point the church
and imperial parties meant much more and many
other things to many other people then just
the power struggle between the church and
the Holy Roman Empire.
Plus if you think about it, it isn’t that
big of a stretch that after so much fighting
through multiple generations, the reasons
for ones loyalty to their party became skewed
to say the least.
So at the start of the 14th century, the prelude
to the war of the bucket, was a multiple centuries
long power struggle between the church and
the Holy Roman Empire that turned so out of
hand and created so many feuds in northern
Italy, that now even the Pope and the Emperor
denounced some of the acts committed by both
factions.
Hope you enjoyed the video.
To be honest the whole church vs empire factions
of medieval Italy is a subject so complex
many of dissertations have been written on
it and therefor I had to skip or simplifi
a lot of nuencoses or details that shaped
certain overarching decisions.
Thus there’s a lot of footnotes in the description
that are trying to explain some of it and
if you want to know more there’re always
sources in my scripts.
Lastly, if you’re looking forward to the
War of the Bucket video that will be coming
out on my channel at some point, consider
subscribing and maybe hitting that bell icon,
because the truth is, the war of bucket, actually
did not happen as portrayed in all of these
youtube videos.